it's here
it's in there
very very
thank you
oh
[Music]
he's right there
uh
[Music]
um
yes
uh
[Music]
uh
the radius
over there
oh
just walked over to the two of them
just telling everyone that rosie is
actually not shut down
foreign
i don't think she's gonna sit down i
don't think she's gonna sit down either
with everyone i think
she's walking
[Applause]
[Applause]
good morning
good morning mr president good morning
madam ambassador who is with us this
morning madam ambassador
[Applause]
ambassador matarova
mr president it is my honor to present
to you the congress of the united states
which has great respect and admiration
and appreciation for your courageous
leadership members of congress i have
the high privilege and distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of
ukraine vladimir zelensky
[Applause]
my colleagues slava ukrana
lava guccina
glory to heroes
thank you very much madam speaker
members of the congress ladies and
gentlemen
americans friends
i'm proud to greet you from ukraine from
our capital city of cave a city that is
under missile and air strikes from
russian troops
every day
but it doesn't give up
and we have not even thought about it
for a second
just like many other
cities and communities in our beautiful
country which found themselves in the
worst war since world war ii
i have the honor to greet you on behalf
of the ukrainian people brave
and freedom-loving people who for eight
years
have been resisting the russian
aggression those who give their best
sons and daughters to stop
this full-scale
russian invasion
right now
the destiny of our country
is being decided
the destiny of our people whether
ukrainians will be free whether they
will be able to preserve their democracy
russia has attacked not just us not just
our land not just our cities it went on
a brutal offensive against our values
basic human values it through tanks and
planes against our freedom against our
right to live freely in our own country
choosing our own
future
against our desire for happiness against
our national dreams
just like the same dreams you have you
americans
just
like anyone else in the united states i
remember your national memorial in
rushmore
the faces of your prominent presidents
those who laid the foundation of the
united states of america as it is today
democracy independence freedom and care
for everyone for every person for
everyone who works diligently who lives
honestly who respects the law we in
ukraine want the same for our people
all
that is
normal part of your own life
ladies and gentlemen
friends americans
in your great history you have pages
that would allow you to understand
ukrainians understand us now when you
need
it
right now when we need you right now
remember pearl harbor
terrible morning of december 7 1941 when
your sky was black from the plains
attacking you
just remember it
remember september the 11th a terrible
day in 20 2001 when evil tried to turn
your cities
independent territories
in battlefields when
innocent people were attacked
attacked from air yes
just like nobody else expected it you
could not stop it our
country
experience the same every day right now
at this moment every night for three
weeks now
various ukrainian cities odessa and
heart
heavens
russia has turned the ukrainian sky
into a source of death
for thousands of people
russian troops have already fired nearly
1 000 missiles at ukraine countless
bombs they use drones to kill
us with precision this is a terror that
europe has not seen has not seen for 80
years and we are asking for a reply for
an answer to this uh terror from the
whole world is this a lot to ask for to
create a no-fly zone zone over ukraine
to save people is this too much to ask
humanitarian no-fly on
something that ukraine that russia would
not be able to terrorize our free cities
if this is too much to ask
we offer an alternative you know
what kind of defense systems we need as
300 and other similar systems you know
how much depends on the battlefield on
the ability to use aircraft powerful
strong air
aviation to protect our people our
freedom our land
aircraft that can help ukraine
help
europe
and you know
that they
exist and you have them
but they are on earth not in ukraine in
the ukrainian sky
they do not defend our people i have a
dream these words are known to each of
you today i can say i have a need
i need to protect
our sky i need your decision your help
which means exactly the same the same
you feel when you hear the words i have
a dream
ladies and gentlemen
friends
ukraine is grateful to the united states
for its overwhelming support for
everything that u.s government and your
people have done for us for weapons
and ammunition for training for finances
for leadership in the free world which
helps us to pressure the aggressor
economically i'm grateful to president
biden for his personal involvement
for his sincere commitment to the
defense of ukraine and democracy all
over the world i am grateful to you for
the resolution which recognizes all
those who commit crimes against ukraine
against the ukrainian people as war
criminals however now
it is true in the darkest time for our
country for the whole europe i call on
you to do more new packages of sanctions
are needed constantly every week until
the russian military machine stops
restrictions are needed for everyone on
whom this unjust regime is based
we propose that the united states
sanctions all politicians in the russian
federation who remain in their offices
and do not
[Music]
cut ties with those who are responsible
for the aggression against ukraine from
state dumas members to the last official
who has lack of morale to break the
state terror all americans company
must leave russia from their market
leave their market
immediately because it is flooded with
our blood
ladies and gentlemen members of congress
please take the lead if you have
companies in your districts who
finance the russian military machine
leaving business in russia you should
put pressure i'm asking to make sure
that the russians do not receive a
single penny that they use to destroy
people in ukraine
the destruction of our country the
destruction of europe all american ports
should be closed for uh russian goods
we um
peace is more important than income and
we have to defend this principle in the
whole world we already became
part of the anti-work coalition a big
anti-war coalition that unites
many countries dozens of countries those
who reacted to in principle to president
putin's decision to invade our country
but we need to move on and do more we
need to create
new tools to respond quickly and stop
the war the full-scale russian invasion
of ukraine which began on february 24th
and it would be fair if it ended in a
day
in 24 hours that evil would be punished
immediately
today
the world does not have
such tools
the war of the past have prompted our
predecessors to create institutions
that should protect us from war
but
they unfortunately don't work we see it
you see it so we need new ones new
institutions new alliances and we offer
them we propose to create an association
you 24 united for these a union of
responsible countries then heavily
strengthened from this consciousness to
stop conflicts immediately provide all
the necessary assistance in 24 hours if
necessary even weapons necessary
humanitarian support political support
finance everything you need to keep
the peace can quickly
save the world to save lives in addition
such associations
natural disasters and new disasters who
felt victims to humanitarian grasses or
epidemics remember how difficult it was
for the world to do the simplest thing
just to give
vaccines passions against food to save
lives to prevent new strengths the world
spent months years doing things like
that much faster to make sure there are
no human losses
no victims ladies and gentlemen
americans
if such allies will insist today that in
24 we will be able to save thousands of
lives in our country
in many countries of the world
those who need peace
those who
suffer inhumane destruction
i ask you to watch one video video
of what the russian truth did
in our country in our land
we have to stop it
we must
prevent it preventively destroy every
single aggressor who seeks to
subjugate other nations
um
[Music]
moment
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
ugh
[Applause]
and
in the end to sum it up
today
today
to be the leader of the age
today
[Music]
being
the leader of the world means
to be the leader of this
peace
in your country doesn't depend anymore
only on you and your people
it depends on those
next to you
and those who are strong
strong doesn't mean
big
strong
is brave and ready to fight for the life
of his citizens and citizens of the
world for human rights dream for the
right to live instantly and to die when
your time comes
and not plan is wanted by someone else
by your neighbor
today
the ukrainian people
are defending not only grain
we are fighting for the values of europe
and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the american people are
helping
not just ukraine
but europe
and the world to keep the blood alive
to keep justice
in history
now i am almost 45 years old
today my age soft where my heart all
more than my other children
are beating
i see
no sense in life
if it cannot stop
the death
and this is my main mission and believe
all my people
great
brains and as the leader
of my nation i'm addressing
the president
you are the leader
of the niche
of your vision
i wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means
to be the leader
of this
thank you
[Applause]
it always
all right
[Music]
thank you
oh
let's go
okay
i know
oh
hmm
um somewhere
[Music]
guys
you know
if that's what they want
yeah on tv
okay
so will
okay
should i cut this down
yeah
i'm still shooting
she's talking with
pelosi
if i get these two guys out of the way
i'm pretty sure
okay
oh
all right
i know yeah